Qué mensaje Busca china emitir con Esta
visita y en qué tan creíble es el plan
de paz de 12 puntos presentado por
Beijing Washington dice que el mundo no
debe dejarse engañar
bueno China ha tomado un nuevo rol en la
Esfera Global en las relaciones
internacionales Más allá de su espacio
regional ha querido intervenir en un
social a las hostilidades entre Arabia
Saudita e Irán y de la misma forma ya
desde un principio de la Guerra de
Ucrania el presidente
sí no asumió una postura
tanta gente como como occidente en
contra de Rusia pero tampoco
menospreció no la lucha de parte del
pueblo ucraniano ahí me parece que es
muy importante esta reunión si no me
equivoco luego de la reunión con
Vladimir Putin el presidente chino tiene
programada una llamada telefónica con
el presidente de Ucrania y hay unos
intereses económicos detrás de todo de
todo esta negociaciones que él quisiera
que se volvieran en negociaciones de paz
pero no obstante hay un punto muy
muy claro en su visita y es descartar el
uso de armas nucleares en este conflicto
y me parece que también entre los puntos
que ya china había mencionado que deben
los doce puntos que china propone para
un plan de paz también habla de respetar
no la soberanía de los pueblos por lo
tanto aunque hemos querido se ha querido
proyectar una imagen de que china tomó
una un partido no que tomó un lado
apoyando a Vladimir Putin Me parece que
han sido muy cautelosos y que sus doce
puntos demuestran que han sido
pragmáticos y están buscando también sus
beneficios no olvidemos que Rusia y
Ucrania son dos socios comerciales muy
importantes para china china es el socio
comercial más importante para Rusia y
también lo era de Ucrania china Tenía
muchos negocios en Ucrania se ha
afectado mucho la cadena de suministros
en relación a ciertos productos de
alimenticios no Por lo tanto china me
parece que está buscando una estabilidad
una salida una
que empieza al menos un diálogo pero
también hay que puntualizar que su
comentario en relación a la soberanía de
los pueblos y sobre a no utilizar las
armas nucleares claramente
no es que lo pongan en contra a Vladimir
Putin pero como ciertos círculos dentro
de Rusia ha hablado el uso de armas
nucleares para defender el los intereses
rusos me parece que es muy importante
que le demos atención a eso y también
que no lo menospreciemos esta esta
negociaciones creo que son importantes y
creo que pueden tener Eh
puede ser pueden traer un desarrollo
concreto hacia empezar a un cese de
hostilidades que alguna negociación en
términos del aspecto humanitario
Y es que junto a todo lo que Comenta
Además del pragmatismo Chino respecto al
conflicto la relación entre ambas
potencias Aunque de amistad amistad
tiene también sus puntos de desencuentro
puede aprovechar China la situación de
Rusia para tener a Moscú bazo bajo
cierto control
absolutamente a mí me parece es un
ironía no en la historia en los 60 china
era menospreciaba como como una potencia
política y regional en el área por lo
que era la unión soviética no hay muchos
anécdotas sobre los encontronazos que
tenía o el controlador no o el
menosprecio de Nikita crushoff hacia el
líder en aquel entonces así que vemos
como 60 años o más y China como quien
dice Ahora tiene otra
tiene otro perfil y Rusia se ve obligada
a básicamente suplicar por ayuda y para
que siga suministrando cierto material
que es bien importante para su
maquinaria de la guerra no no esté
vendiendole armas militares pero tal vez
material que es necesario para su
reparación por lo tanto me parece que
china se va a aprovechar muchísimo de
este momento histórico en el cual Rusia
está sumamente debilitado y a pesar de
que no ha sucumbido a las sanciones ha
tenido que depender demasiado de China
Rusia en comparación a la economía de
China es minúscula no china No necesita
a Rusia para seguir desarrollándose
económicamente pero Rusia Ahora sí
necesita China para poder subsistir y no
colapsar